going back
bring the fishing
and wonders
flowing
gentle back to the front keep the arms
up and again they allow them to flow
down
keep them slightly in front of the body
and we're going to turn the hands up and
over
and then reverse it the other way
you have these big rotations going right
into the shoulder sockets
keep a slight Bend in the elbows and as
you're doing the movement gradually
start to bring the arms out to the side
you're working your way up to shoulder
height
the shoulder height just pause
turn to look at one hand
turn the other hand over as far as
everybody
keep a slight Bend in the elbows and the
movement is to turn your head to the
other side to turn in the hands over
the center
some of you might want to turn sideways
onto your mat
and then bring your hands down to the
mats
so if anyone hasn't done this next part
before you might just want to stand up
or look up
I'm going to look at one hand and I'm
going to make sure I'm looking at the
hand at all times as I draw the elbow
straight back
and then extend the elbow
and looking up at the hand
and then collapse the elbow back in and
it is straight down to the mat so it
doesn't come out to the side of the
swooping action
elbow back
stand in the elbow
looking up at the hand at all times
bring it back in and then straight out
when your hand is above you you want the
Palm to be facing over the back of your
body
and then you come back to the start
position by coming up
and coming down on the other side
and then we sit down on the mats
breathe out
and
exactly
and I keep breathing out because
working with the energy
control your breathing
try to regulate us